[Musique]
aujourd'hui présenter alien un film de
ridescott de 1979 écrit par Dano banane
donc aliens c'est le deuxième film de
rilès Scott après les dieux listes alors
faut savoir que Ridley Scott par contre
avait eu toute une très grande carrière
dans la publicité avant donc il est
arrivé sur le tard entre guillemets au
cinéma les deux vis d'ailleurs qui
étaient qui avaient été à Cannes mais
alien n'est que entre guillemets en
deuxième film beaucoup de choses ont été
dit aussi sur alien et sur tout le
sous-tex sexuel sur le viol sur la place
de la femme sur tout ça mais alien c'est
aussi finalement on le vend souvent
quand les finition mais surtout un film
d'horreur dans l'espace on voit que très
peu le monstre elle est en question il y
a toute une atmosphère de tension qui a
créé tous les codes du genre du film
d'horreur sont là plus que du film de SF
alien finalement cette histoire de
router l'espace qui prennent en stop une
créature et derrière tout va très très
mal se passer c'est un film qui est
assez incroyable parce qu'il était deux
ans après Star Wars et après du coup
Star Wars
[Musique]